The first thing that I notice when I look at this version of our term is that we
actually don't need these dots between the variables, and actually we don't need
a multiplication sign between 2 and x either. Inside a term the only place we
really need to explicitly indicate multiplication with the multiplication sign
is between the constants. Factors, the reason that we really had to write them
in between the 5, the 7, and the 2 before, was the dot, this didn't look like we
were writing 572 x, y, z. So to start off, I'm just going to get rid of those 3
unnecessary multiplication signs. Remember if you kept them in, your term is
still mathematically correct. It just contains a couple of extra symbols that
don't necessarily need to be there. So now we have this 5 times 7 times 2 to
deal with. Those are just numbers and we know how to multiply numbers together,
5 times 7 is 35. And 35 times 2 is 70. So we can replace 5 times 7 times 2 with
70, and write the remaining factors afterward, xyz.